[موسيقى]
على طول الساحل الشمالي الشرقي لجمهورية الدومينيكان
هي واحدة من جواهر التاج في البلاد.
I tsys National Park los
ITSs والتي تترجم إلى
أرض جبلية هي موطن للغابات المطيرة المورقة ،
كهوف المنغروف المذهلة المزينة بنقوش
صخرية ومئات من أنواع الطيور
المفقودة.
حديقة وطنية في عام 1976 تغطي
مساحة تزيد عن 618 ميلًا مربعًا ، لذا فلا
عجب أن تكون الغابات المطيرة في المنتزهات
موقع تصوير لـ Jurassic Park من
التكوين الصخري الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه 100 قدم
فجأة خارج الماء إلى
الكهوف المختلفة وأشجار المانغروف ، الحديقة هي موطن
بعض الموائل المتنوعة بشكل لا يصدق بينما
تقع لاسها في جزء بعيد من
الجزيرة ، يقوم العديد من الزوار برحلة
لتجربة جمال
المناظر الطبيعية المتنوعة بمجرد دخولهم ، يمكنهم التنزه أو
التجديف في طريقهم عبر المنتزه الضخم
[موسيقى]